hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that my guest
today is a man whose story is truly
shocking he is a former neo-nazi who
when he was just 17 years old beat a man
so badly that he died of his injuries
now after that he spent a number of
years in prison during which time he
became a Christian and started a new
life and here he is johannes can i phone
Yanis thank you very much for joining me
today here on talking Germany welcome
now when I say that Johannes can Eiffel
started a new life what I mean is that
he studied theology and went on to
become a church pastor and many people
are impressed by the road that he has
gone down by the remorse that he has
shown some though are not convinced by
his apparent change of heart
Yanis when you sit opposite me and you
hear me telling a television audience
about the crime that you committed how
painful is it for you is it painful for
you just a little bit of painful because
that it means that when you look at me
you'll still see my past and and I am
still the person for you but beating up
a man and he died and you don't seem a
man I am today 100% and I was still a
shadow of a past and and that's painful
because I want people see me like I am
today tell me tell me the difference I
mean the events were many years ago you
were 17 obviously back then you spent
many years in prison what's the
difference between the 17 year old that
you were then and the person you are now
I was a searching person when I was 17 I
was searching for my way to life I was
searching for for there eul's
I can build my life upon and excuse me
that makes you sound out almost like in
and
now idealist I was an idealist but you
were a very angry idealist oh yeah I was
done is that the combination is that
perhaps who you were was a part of who I
was and and a very important part was
when I was a fighting person I grew up
and life always was a struggle and I had
enemies
I had many fights to fight and so I
learned that life is dangerous and to
stay alive you must be hard you must be
strong and it tried to be I try to be
hard I try to be strong I try to be a
good friend to my friends and I did it
you have to go away you have the wrong
friends perhaps I had the wrong friends
but I had no other friends and and so
nobody can live for his own they were my
only friends and so that was a way I
lived it's interesting listening to what
you say and it's a very complicated very
complex series of events one aspect of
your story is that you now have a second
chance
do you believe why do you believe that
you deserve a second chance
everybody deserves that because we all
are humans um we all we all make
mistakes and we all need the chance to
to learn from mistakes and to make a new
beginning and everybody wants it for
himself but we have problems to give
others the same chance but we want for
ourselves and so everybody should look
at himself and nobody can can live his
life without a second chances and so we
all
should give this a second or third or
fourth chances to ours okay Alice thank
you for those first thoughts we've
clearly got an awful lot to talk about
those were your first impressions of
Johannes conniver
he is more Johannes conniver says he's
seen the light today he's a pastor and
leads a free Baptist congregation in the
ask iboga region of eastern Germany he
says his life was once dark brutal and
fractured but he's put that behind him
now his world at age 17 was Germany's
radical neo-nazi scene johannes canada
was a staunch skinhead he referred to
his mother who had multiple sclerosis as
a [ __ ] and called his blind father a
loser in boarding school he led a double
life during the day johannes was a
bright well-behaved pupil evenings and
at the weekends he was a racist hatred
of foreigners dominated his worldview
back then the former headmaster at the
boarding school recalls how Johannes
kannathil drifted into the neo-nazi
scene Ben music ah that's your honey I'm
certain that Johannes fell in with the
wrong group of friends I should find
they could manipulate him more
powerfully than we were able to directed
one friend called mark o/s became a role
model for kunafa with and for him kuniva
became a skinhead and a criminal in
august 1999 the two broke into this
house where pated dortmund was living
locally known as hippie he was one of
the few people brave enough to stand up
to the militant extremists and paid for
it with his life Johannes conniver was
sentenced to five years in Germany's
largest juvenile prison on charges of
assault and battery resulting in death
even the psychologists gave up on him
they testified he was incorrigible while
in jail he encountered foreigners at
first there were fights then later
reflection prison chaplain detox was
there when kannathil renounced the
radical right and began to attend church
services he's convinced that novice
change of heart was genuine from the
beginning Johannes was someone who could
never get over his guilt a short Knick
fan that's what prompted him to start
asking some serious questions years
later Johannes novel visited the
anonymous grave of his victim he said it
was a confrontation with his own guilt
and the start of a new life can I feel
joy naff research and read the Bible
instead of neo-nazi propaganda he
decided to become a pastor and wrote
term papers and did pastoral internships
as a theology student he also recorded
his story in a book he says it's a
painful reckoning with himself but
critics say Kani fall is merely
grandstanding at his victims expense he
has experienced the depths and a new
beginning and today he's our guest on
talking Germany johannes sniper
your honors can Eiffel I think we should
begin at the end of that report and then
go back to somewhere near the beginning
you've you've written this book about
your own experiences you come you come
on television shows like this one yeah
and some people we heard it at the end
of the report say that's distasteful
they say they accuse you of drawing
attention to yourself
what do you say to those people most
people a minority
we are very loud and aggressive in
saying the opinion but we are only few
and 99% or more I glad that I do the way
I do and they are thankful for the
things I tell them and several people
changed their lives because we heard of
my story and and so I give our society a
lot and I say I do and I don't have only
friends and someone doesn't like me it's
very life is someone done it doesn't
like your work and and so it's with me
and we should not concentrate on most
minorities but let's go back okay in
time to your very early days when you
were a real youngster five six seven
eight nine ten years old you you said
yourself you had a terrible childhood we
got a couple of impressions from it
there tell us about your childhood in
your own words I was I was a lost child
and you were lost I felt lost I I felt
like a stranger
I was very try
did you know Sofia fearful and and I did
feel a laughter my I didn't feel barfi
and and and so um did you have people
you could talk to you know I what about
in your family I mean you have problems
with your parents but when our brothers
is family um there was so much problems
that nobody was able to talk about the
problems and our parents didn't talk to
us about their problems and and I didn't
learn but I could talk about my problems
and so the only friends I had we were
also children a lot of difficult
families and it was good for us because
we didn't have to talk about our parents
we were shamed of you're talking about
other people hear all the time about
what other people gave you or didn't
give you you could have done things
differently as well I mean you you you
were we heard in the river you never
were very cruel to your parents you said
to your mother she was but handled I
didn't your father wasn't good enough
you scorned him I I didn't learn empathy
and and and so I I saw all the problems
maybe maybe I felt the problems but they
were too hard and and so I closed the
door to my heart or something else and
why given all that you are telling me
did you drift into the skinhead scene
into the far-right scene because that
wasn't I'm you know my sense is that
that's not a place that would give you
you know would give you love and it
wasn't laughs but it was a community a
brotherhood or something they gave me a
feeling they were my friends and there
also gave me solutions for problems I
saw
their solutions didn't work but but I I
hoped why did you believe in all this
because I mean you're a very bright guy
you're a very intelligent guy and you
stand you-you-you're in circles where
there are people who've got very simple
formulaic answers to the problems of the
world present why did you buy into that
one point the people that I called my
friends they lived their life with her
thoughts and everything and in life I
lived by ideology and and I I didn't
know some other people living their
lives such radical and and that
fascinated me
the other thing was I felt very very
small and I fought it like in great
German at under of Hitler Germany was
fighting and and what was getting
greater and greater and rural dominated
Europe or almost the world you can
you're you're an intelligent guy you
knew that terrible things had happened
in Nazi Germany you know I knew it but I
thought everything has his price and I
fought it it could so at the time this
was it wasn't just about guys being
together and bonding and being friends
it was you were at the time you were
effectively you were a racist you
weren't and so I was I was and I think
is easy to if other people the good of
problems and
paint build to have an enemy to create
to see somebody is an enemy to make your
life easier I had many problems
I couldn't grasp and and saw I had a
enemy I could fight against you could
blind okay well we've heard about the
neo-nazi seen that Johannes conniver got
involved in in the state of Lower Saxony
in western Germany that's now moved to
eastern Germany where there are in some
areas worrying concentrations of
right-wing extremism such as in the town
of spring bag which lies about 150
kilometers southeast of the Berlin
Yohannes you are somebody who knows
about the kind of problems that we're
talking about here from the inside and
from the outside law I know you thought
about these things an awful lot the
mayor of sprain burg has no idea how to
deal with the problem that she's
confronted with do you have a suggestion
of any kind yeah problem is that she
sits on a table and in her building and
people for young people extremists on
the streets and we didn't find together
and it's very important that we see us
as human beings living in the same town
and that we communicate with one another
and listening and talking three hours
and there are problems in this town and
she has to listen about problems but she
also has to talk to people to radical
people too and and very important
appoint young people young men need role
models and in the context that I live
there are only few role models and the
male role models we find of them our
criminal extremists and so they live
away with it have them and so it's very
important that normal men go to young
men and show them but they can live
another way and so teachers or normal
workers every man is asked to go to a
young men and show them how they'd do
their lives and what values they have in
their lives and I should lead by example
and it's very important you to live in
eastern Germany are you on a day to day
basis are you confronted you see the
same kind of problems around you are you
involved in a process where you two
could possibly be a role model or
somebody
involved in a dialogue I be a role model
and I try to be present but one mins is
not enough and where there's need for
more to do that but I I don't want to
look away van dice when I see problems
and I won't want to talk to young men
when I when I see them and when I see it
they are aggressive or violent and it's
important not to look away and to go to
a person's and to tell them in which
direction a way of life will lead and
and to show them that my life can be in
our way we want and one thing that you
have done it and in that sense you have
been a role model to an extent is that
you have broken away from the far right
scene have you have there been you know
have you come under pressure physically
or in terms if I don't know what not not
physically physically on but yeah there
are pages and the internet write about
me and but what if I say yeah
concluding but I wouldn't live and to
the way I do if we ruling Germany that's
it's it's about it's about fear and I
want to make people fearing them and if
I can do so and they are successful but
I don't have fear for from anybody and
and and so I left my baby because it's
it's the right thing and I do so one
contribution he made was by writing the
book of you have you got any indication
whatsoever that people in the room young
men young women in the right wing scene
have actually read your book
I don't know if some of them retreated I
hope so
at least we heard about my story and I
can think about it we have a possibility
to read the book or to to see this
student so it's they are responsible for
their lives and I can tell them it's the
wrong way and we should turn around and
start a new life but they have to do so
and we want oh I could try to help them
but it's it's man decision okay with
young criminals there are two things you
can do you can speak to them and you can
help them or you can punish them and one
special provision of German law is
called yugantar at juvenile detention
it's a kind of short sharp shock young
offenders spend maybe a weekend maybe a
week or two but no longer than four
weeks in prison the idea is to give them
a foretaste of just how miserable their
lives inside prison will be if they
continue to commit crimes
Yanis can Eiffel I wonder what you were
thinking while you were watching that
report it is pedagogical instrument and
it doesn't work and it doesn't work why
doesn't it work because it's not about
punishment and it's about teaching in
education and you can punish young
people as hard as you want it won't make
them better people ha
we have have them develop the skills and
teach them the right very use and teach
from social skills for some people that
would sound like rewarding young people
for the crimes that they've committed
making it too easy for them I don't see
it was because people who are ending in
jail we had a much harder life than
other people mostly um there are some
examples but most of young inmates very
much problems in very young lives and
and so it's not a rule you're rewarding
its equal our problems ever had and
still happened and the society as good
tasks to equal problems and and to give
input to those young men it's
interesting in your book at the
beginning of your book you there's a
dedication for the people who had stood
by you despite everything and I wonder
because you're talking about the you
know the educational impact that the the
prison life can have on you that can
take place during a time when you're in
prison was there was there somebody in
prison and on prison staff who actually
stood by you who actually was a role
model for you I had a teacher my class
cousin and my education
was like a lack of power for me and it
was very important on because he told me
perspective I didn't have beforehand and
it was there for me and and it was very
very important and he said to me one
time but I am I like a sign of it he had
never had and and that was very very
important for me because I never heard
such a sentence from my debt and and so
it it was it was great and it helped me
a lot to feel aft and to feel that there
are people were interested in my life
and who wanted to help me make the best
of my life and so it was also motivation
for me not to disappoint those people
sure a big step forward another I think
another lesson that you had when you
were in prison was that I mean you said
yourself you had had racist views when
you were a teenager and then there you
were in prison sharing your immediate
environment with people from immigrant
communities and possibly foreigners as
well so two people from a very different
cultural background from yourself what
did you learn there they were the first
people I met of it gave me a second
chance and was very important and they
became the best friends I had in in my
entire life and way their company I'm
like a family member like a Bravo and
also I was a racist when I get prison
and and but help me to start in your
life and it was very important and also
our life and then prisoners is very gray
and boring and the multicultural
friendships I had brought um Carlson in
with 'life and they helped me
to fill the time with new experiences
and it was very important I was afraid
foreign people when I get to prison and
they learned that foreigners are no
threat but they are in enrichment the
third important experience you had when
you were in prison is that you became a
Christian I mean that come about it came
because they were people and they showed
me that I'm but I am a creator by God
and I'm laughed by God and Jesus died
either cross for me and my sins and
finally I made an experience that the
God we were talking about still alive
and is talking by itself to me and but
you really forgive me my sins and wants
to start in your life with me and it was
a great spiritual experience and and we
changed on my heart and have to help me
starting your life
a very interesting report tell us about
how that community that we were just
hearing about there compares with your
community is your community also
shrinking and as a small community but
is dislike video for all Church
Christianity wasn't a major movement and
it started small and to get larger and
bigger and reach the people and so it's
our task good day we we are a small
group and we have to reach the people
tell them about Jesus bring them the
gospel and I'm convinced that people's
life will will change when they met
Jesus and and make spiritual experiences
and much things oneness miracles can
happen in one way that you're making a
contribution we ask people to bring
people along sort of cherished personal
possessions this is what you've chosen
to bring along today it's a sort of a
song book from from an adventure camp
that you've been involved in I think
that's what I would call it yeah just
tell us a little bit about why it's so
important to you
I'm just important for me because I told
you I was a lost child and the children
become - I lost our children - and their
parents I'm in prisons and and so we
have much difficulties familiar and and
social and of all the shame when father
or mother or both are in prison and
poverty and and violence and we don't
live at right hood a shoot and so we
give them one or two times a year the
chance to be a child and to have fun and
to be laughed and to sing songs many of
them didn't sing songs before and it's
it's great to see in a few days but
young people they have not no good words
when they come and and we change in some
days and and they begin to laugh and to
sing and to build friendships and it's
it's so such an important
welcome to to give read young people
laugh and it's not not much it's only
one week or two weeks a year what I
think it makes a difference in their
lives and it's clearly I mean I'm it's
it's a great contribution to making
their significant contribution what
you're talking about is giving people a
chance possibly giving people a second
chance and the theme of our conversation
is that you've been you've been given a
second chance yourself which is a which
i think is a very a very good thing
one person who's not willing to give you
a second chance is the daughter not yet
but maybe evicted or maybe some maybe
someday real young and it takes time to
forgive and and take times wounds will
heal and and I hope in a private the day
will come but today it hasn't come
that's a painful thing for you
suggesting it's painful what I'm
reliving often and not in heaven and so
we have to end your pain it's it's part
of our lives about to ask you one more
personal question your highness you
you've you've I think you've been
fortunate enough in recent years to have
experienced love being given to you by
other people other adult people have you
been capable of giving love back yeah
and it's it's a great thing to do so and
I know it's when I stand before a person
and I see fear or pain in their eyes and
in the recent years I stood before many
persons and I saw thankfulness and enjoy
in their eyes because we were meeting me
and I gave them my words or my
experiences or my feelings and I had
people and that's great and
it's a good thing too to be laughs but -
laughs - also we're going to have to
leave it there on those words your
highness that is all the time we have on
today's show my guest has been johannes
can Eiffel who committed a terrible
crime as a young man but is being given
a second chance
bye-bye
you